- [Voiceover] We're now
going to start looking at
ecology, which is just the
study of how life interacts
with other life or how
living things interact
with each other and their environment.
And you you could think of it well how
is life interacting with living beings?
So that's the technical term often given
as biotic factors,
biotic factors, you have
the word bio in there
signaling life,
or non-living things, abiotic factor.
A is the prefix often for not,
so abiotic is not living,
not living factors, and those
are just the technical terms,
but if you even think about
yourself as you watch this video
you are in an environment,
you are interacting with it.
There are many abiotic
factors around you that you
might notice, the air
that you are breathing,
the temperature, your access to water,
but there's also biotic factors.
Even if you think you're in a room alone,
you're not fully, you're
not completely alone.
There is bacteria around you that
you might not see.
There might be other forms of life,
you might have a plant in the room.
Those are the biotic factors
that you are interacting with.
That plant in that room
might be producing oxygen
that you are then breathing,
or you're producing carbon
dioxide which that plant
is able to fix and grow.
And it might be interacting
with abiotic factors
like sunlight to in
order to that it uses in
photosynthesis in order to fix the carbon.
We study all of that in
some depth in biology,
and really ecology is a
bit of a synthesis of a lot
of what we learn, if
anything, all of what we learn
in biology because it's taking life,
it's studying life at another level
where it's not just the
individual organism anymore,
and it's not even just the
population or the community,
but we're talking about
an even bigger system that
is incredibly complex and that's why it's
a really interesting thing to study.
Now all of these images here
are things that folks would
associate with an ecosystem.
Over here you have a coral reef,
and some of the life is obvious,
you see the coral, you see the fish here,
but there's also life
that you're not seeing.
There's going to be bacteria in this water
that's not visible at
least in the picture.
And the abiotic factors are going to
be things like the water temperature,
or frankly, just even
the existence of water,
or the salt content of the water,
or other minerals that are in the water.
In these pictures over here,
you don't necessarily see the animal life,
but there is for sure
going to be if you were
to dig into this grass or
look through those bushes
you will find animal life,
you will find insects, you
will find other animals.
The trees are life,
so that's going to be
part of the ecosystem.
If we're studying ecology we think about
well how do these trees
interact with the water,
how do they interact
with the other species?
How do they provide shelter for them?
Or food?
Or how are they dependent
on the other life
in some way to grow?
Same thing for in this case the mushrooms.
How does the fungus living
on this tree branch,
or in conjunction with the
moss and whatever else?
All of this is the study of ecology,
the study of ecosystems.
Now when folks are talking about ecology
they like to talk about different scales.
And so let's now think
about the different scales
within an ecosystem, or
even beyond an ecosystem.
So I have some pictures that
if you watch a wildlife show
you typically see some images like this,
and so since we at least
are familiar with it,
at least on TV hopefully we
get to visit this at some
point in our life, let's just
think about the different
characters here on the
different ecological scales.
So at the most basic
scale is the individual.
So let me write this down,
you have the individual.
So if we were talking
about these elephants,
the individual would be
one individual elephant
right over there.
Now the next scale is the population,
the next scale is the population,
and if we were to stick with
our African savanna theme
right over here, the population,
you have an individual
elephant, the population
would be the members
of that same species
that live in that area.
So in this case the population would be,
would at least include
these elephants that we see
in this picture, there might
be a couple of elephants
that are off the picture,
and I should say in
particular these are going to
be the African elephants.
So it's the members of the same species
that are living in the same place.
And it's up for the classifier,
or the scientist,
whoever is studying it to define
what do we mean by
living in the same place?
We might define it as the people,
you know, the people
(laughs), the elephants
that live within a few
miles of this watering hole.
You might define it as
the elephants that live
within a broader area,
it could be you know,
that live in East Africa, or South Africa,
whatever it might be.
And so defining the population is
all the members of a species
that live in an area,
but that area is up for definition.
Now the next level up is the community,
is the community.
And that is all the living things that
might live in that area
however we define the area.
So for example, if this
lion and this giraffe
lives in the area that we
used to define the population
they would be members of the community.
Let me circle that,
so they would be members of the community.
And it wouldn't even
just be the big animals
that you see here, it
would include all the life
that is in that area.
So it would include the
vegetation that is in the area,
it would include the bacteria,
it would include the fungus,
it would include any animals that
are living inside of this
water that you would see there.
Now if you go even one more
level of kind of inclusion,
then we go to the ecosystem.
So then we go, I'll go down here,
then you go to an ecosystem.
And what an ecosystem is,
it's all of the living
things in that community,
so all of the living things in an area,
and then you're also adding
the non-living things,
the abiotic factors.
So you're including the rock,
and the air, and the
weather, and the clouds,
and the water itself that is
part of that watering hole.
And a lot of times you
might think that the
abiotic factors well they for sure affect,
they for sure affect the biotic factors.
If you don't have water,
or if the temperature
is too cold or too hot
it might be hard for a
certain type of life to thrive,
but it goes both ways.
The biotic factors affect
the abiotic factors.
We have oxygen in our
environment due to life on Earth.
They might also affect the various,
the chemical composition of
certain parts of the abiotic
factors, say the water, or
the soil, or whatever else.
And if you want to get a
level above an ecosystem,
then sometimes you'll hear
people talk about a biosphere.
Biosphere, which is, you can think of it
as a meta-ecosystem, or
oftentimes in my head
I view it as a fully, it
contains all of the ecosystems
that are in some way
connected to each other.
So a fully enclosed,
fully contained ecosystem.
And biospheres are actually,
well I guess the most
famous biosphere (laughs)
or the one that we're
typically referring to
is we could refer to the
whole Earth as a biosphere.
It has multiple ecosystems,
and once again,
ecosystems, it depends what
the researcher wants to
define as an ecosystem.
They could define it as you know,
just something around a certain
river in a certain area,
just like that, or they might define the
ecosystem as a broader region.
But all of the ecosystems in the world
are part of the biosphere that we know as
that is part of Earth.
And it's self-contained
because we don't think
that there are that many influences
from outside of the earth.
Although, even there, we
have to give some credit to
the Sun that is providing
abiotic factors for sure.
We wouldn't have life
on Earth as we know it
without the Sun.
And there's also things like the Moon
the gravitational effect,
you could consider that an abiotic factor,
without the tides we would
not have life as we know it.
But one thing that's really fun,
and as many of you all know
I enjoy science fiction,
is to think about well
what kind of biospheres
could you have if you think
about beyond the Earth?
And this is a depiction here,
this is actually from NASA's website.
How humans could create
biospheres outside of a planet,
and it's this interesting thing where
you know that's quote,
unquote land up here.
Artificially created, and
then you would rotate it
so that there's the perception of gravity.
But anyway, the study of ecosystems,
the study of biospheres, the
study of ecology in general
is incredibly, incredibly fascinating
because when you have
all of this complexity,
each living thing is incredibly complex.
In fact if you want,
you could even sometimes
consider part of a living thing
as an ecosystem in and of itself.
If you were to look even on
the surface of your hand,
you have bacteria living
there that's dependent
on you in some way, and
you might actually benefit
from the bacteria, or actually get hurt
from the bacteria in some way.
So there's all sorts of different scales,
but once you start factoring
everything in together
it becomes these incredibly
beautiful, complex,
often balanced, sometimes
imbalanced systems
that have emergent
properties that start to,
that start to have behaviors
and I want to use that word very loosely
that are somehow described,
or I guess you could say properties
that somehow describe
the ecosystem as a whole.